- What do we got here?
LORI: I have 1800s Sinclair
Scott apple peeler.
Be careful.
You might need a tetanus shot
after you touch that thing.
[laughter]
[apple crunching]
LORI: I came down
to the pawn shop
today to sell my
late-1800s apple peeler.
It doesn't come in handy for me.
It's in pretty good condition.
It just needs to be
polished up a little bit.
Pretty self-explanatory.
It's an apple peeler.
Can I take a look at it?
LORI: Yeah.
All right.
So where in the world
did you get this?
LORI: I got it from
my grandma Betty.
It was passed down
from her grandmother.
It's been in the family for,
I'd say, 100 years or so.
I don't peel my apples,
so I don't really
have any use for it anymore.
I don't think anyone's had use
for that for about 100 years.
When they first
started, they were
more of a commercial thing.
If you were a guy with a
small apple cider company
or something like
that, you would have--
you know, you'd have 10
of these things going.
Right.
People sitting there all
day long cranking them.
The average farmer
in the country,
if his wife asked him for
that, would laugh at her.
LORI: Right.
So how does it work?
You'd stick the
apple on there,
and then clamp this on a
counter or a bench or something,
and screw it on.
It looks like we might be
missing a little flat piece
right there.
And you would crank this, and--
it's little rusty.
LORI: Yeah.
- There you go.
You'd peel your apple.
Sweet.
What do you want
to do with it?
LORI: I'd like to sell it.
Any idea of how much
you're looking to get?
- I was thinking like $90.
- $90?
You know, it's cool.
It's neat.
It doesn't really
have a practical use.
All it is is a
decoration, at this point.
Right.
That being said, I could
probably give you around $50
for it.
- Would you do $75?
- Nope.
I'll go $60.
I'm investing money in an
antique apple peeler here.
It's not-- it's not Apple stock.
- I'd take $60.
- $60?
All right.
Deal.
Yeah.
Thank you.
[inaudible] you
want to write her up?
- Yeah, come on.
- All right.
When he offered me $50, I knew
that that was a good deal.
But I just wanted to
see how far I could go.
I feel good.
I'm going to go and have a
really nice lunch, on them.